folks this is Joe D Roa and I am hitting
that big Open Road in the year 2024 with
my new hour I Never Promised You a Rose
Garden where's it kicking off well it's
kicking off right here in New York City
at the gramar C theater on January 13th
January 19th and 20th I will be at the
comedy Mothership four shows uh doing my
thing in Austin Texas February 8th we
got Nashville at basement East February
9th Charlotte at the underground
February 15th sanf Fran at the Swedish
American Hall folks I then go on
February 16th to Hollywood San Diego on
the 17th then in March we got Palmdale
California Portland Oregon uh Seattle
Washington we're adding more dates every
day also reschedules for the dates I
just had to cancel are coming up so keep
your eye out anyway you want tickets you
want show info go to jod rosa.com that's
jod rosa.com for all info and ticket
links and of course as always if you're
in New York City come on down to Joey
roses we got a new website Joey
roses.com all the info you need is there
come have a sandwich and a drink and
we'll see you soon all right guys I have
one date left of this two-year tour it's
in wils Bear Pennsylvania uh December
16th there's only about 100 tickets left
so get on that if you want to see me
perform this video show for the very
last time other than that new year new
tour with the guys from the Impractical
Jokers we're going everywhere we're
going to Highland California Las Vegas
Nevada Tempe Arizona and we're also
going to Miami on that Cruise January
22nd and then we're doing Hollywood
Florida Tampa cincin Youngstown Ohio uh
we're doing Foxwoods Atlanta Georgia
Mobile Alabama and a bunch more dates
are going to be added just go to
impracticaljokers.com for those
tickets theys going to fight but only
one food can be right tast buds man com
to tties welcome to T buds it's good to
see you buddy the boys are back yeah The
Boys Are Back in Town
ain't no fooling around I have not seen
you in a in human form I haven't seen
you in any form I've texted and called
you see me molecular form when I when I
when I sh shape shape shift but I have
not seen you
in it's got to be a month it's got to be
a full month right
um I don't know I I I I don't have a
memory for that the last time well well
we've had we've had four
I think
four episodes where you weren't here
yeah you met twice I believe yeah and
those were all done consecutively so
it's got to be a month it's got to be
you know four or five weeks or whatever
yeah I was about shooting a special yeah
just back from Chicago everything went
as good as it possibly could so that's
great that's good um just got the uh
links to the to the shows last night
actually so I'll start digging into
those and uh they'll be out probably in
the spring or something like that I'm
going to announce it with the new tour
oh that's great yeah maybe like
something like maybe first week of June
uh it'll drop along with the on sale for
the new tour oh that's great something
in there that's great man you look good
too thanks did you have you been like
working out or something yeah well I've
been I've been it's it's it's been a
journey it's been a journey uh no I've
been I've been eating healthy for I've
been trying to lose weight for the
special particularly and for a couple
other things for a bit it's just that I
I hit the threshold where you can see it
but it's been the process so yeah you
look good you look healthy the uh I have
a cut on my forehead
uh cuz I walked into a door really yes
explain I was drunk okay when I walked
on I was trying to walk out of a bar and
I thought I was within the confines of
the doorway and I was not were you alone
no I was with a girl oh this is even
better is it someone you've known a long
time uh you know you didn't mean it that
night no no no no no no I already knew
this person and you you have a a bruise
so you you hit it with fervor she said
I've never seen anybody's head split
open that easily she goes you didn't
even hit it that hard and it just split
dude it was I was gushing blood to the
point in this bar like holding the we
were leaving to go somewhere else and
then I had to go back into the bar just
sit there holding now you can't leave a
now you can't leave holding a mound of
tissues to my head were you embarrassed
or were you too drunk to be embarrassed
please please um answer as I moisturize
my lips um I could use a little Chap and
I don't have any I don't know if that's
supposed to be a guil trip you're not
getting this people that share chapstick
I think it's nuts I agree um no uh I
can't tell you if I was I I did feel a
certain way about it I don't know if it
was
embarrassment but it was it was more
like God damn it man I can't believe a
situation that the way it's laid out
makes it easy for a person to do it or
was it all
you the next day when I was thinking
about it I was like to be honest I was
kind of like is this a is this some sort
of bottom that I've hit like I walked
into a door like I cut my head open and
when I talked to to the woman I was with
uh I said you know I asked her and she
was like she goes no no she goes you you
barely walked into it and she was like
it was really just like an honest like
you just really you thought you were
like you didn't see it you just hit it
I'm sure the booze had an effect but it
wasn't like I was so drunk I fell down
my stairs wasn't one of those I you have
see those videos where people just walk
straight into a glass wall or whatever
yeah I did that too i' I've done it once
maybe twice but I was on the road and I
was walking back into a back into a
hotel I think into or out I don't
remember but it was all glass doors
right and I was walking full speed and I
slammed my whole body face I slam right
into the wall the glass wall door
whatever it was really and it went it
made the loudest sound it was like a it
was like a a vestibule and then the
lobby and it was like I mean it sounded
like you know like I mean everyone
turned uhuh and the lobby had a lot of
people in it and there was a group of
like a young like maybe like 20-year-old
girls or whatever I don't know a family
but there's like five or six people and
I remember because I was like I played
it like I hit the wall so hard that I
went back I like bounced off of it
and then I was like in shock for a
second because you're processing it for
that Split Second I'm like I just walk
you're hurt you're embarrassed and then
you also trying to make heads or tails
out of the situation yes and then I
looked around and I don't know if it was
necessarily in that moment I was like I
don't know if it was necessarily
apparent it was me because I hit it I
bounced off of it and like if someone
looked right after that and and they
might not be able to pinpoint me
yes and then I was like I can't believe
I just did that and I Swift L it was
going in i i swiftly like opened the
next door to go in and I walked and then
I just heard as soon as I open the door
and started walking I heard the group of
girls and who have the group over there
just start hysterical laughing and I was
like oh that was do you think they knew
who they that you were no I don't I
don't I didn't think that the
uh I mean if they did they probably
would have thought it was like a thing
for the show honestly you know what
that's so funny dude if I had to do that
for the show I wouldn't even blink yeah
they like if they knew you they were
probably like oh my God they're doing
like you know a thing you know but uh
there's no gracious way to come out of
that no there was no this was kind of
late in the evening when this
happened and we were already at we were
already at a bar that I felt like wasn't
crazy about us being
there you were at a bar that wasn't
crazy about YouTu no no just I think
anybody at that was one of those it was
a DIY Joy I thought you were tell me
like you were those people uh we were
just they just didn't really have a
welcoming attitude and I think they were
probably happy enough to lose two more
people to get closer to just W you get
up little did they know you'd be coming
back bleeding yeah and then I had just
sit there and by the way now I'm you
know I got a six-pack of of of Jack and
Jack and diets in me you know right now
no no no now what am I an animal I don't
Jesus said by the way the fact that you
thought that that was possible that I
was doing that might mean it's time to
talk to somebody didn't you preface it
with well now didn't you say the word
now I I meant like at that point in the
evening right but you can see where the
Miss yeah I get you what I'm saying
though is that you accepted it so
quickly that it could be me doing it
right now no I went now okay all right
good that makes me feel better uh so I
had a few in me so I I don't think I was
being the quiet about that I had just
busted my head open were you leveling
accusations at other people
craftsmanship or something I just was
sitting there going how did I do that
how did I do that I just kept and I was
probably really obnoxious I was bleeding
so much that the woman was like I think
we might have to go to the emergency
room no like for stitches and I was like
we we I we can't I can't handle that
right now we have to figure this out and
luckily it just stopped blood thin you
think so alcohol absolutely oh wow I
didn't even think of that yeah
absolutely so the so then why don't
people who need blood thinners just
drink and then I believe they
do many do that's a way more fun way to
thin the blood than did you go to
another bar after that with an open
flesh wound no we called it a night that
was that was kind of the night stops
there the buck stops here at get head
wound um and situation when you got home
dressing bandage no no I just kind of
kept I kept holding it and then
eventually it just eventually like I you
know you put the napkin to it and no
blood is coming out anymore and that's
the end of it that's how that works yeah
and I just I went to bed and and I felt
kind of dumb the next day um maybe
little less dumb than I should have but
at the same time I here's the thing I'm
clutzy period I do when I'm dead
sober clut is a fun word it is I've done
dead sober that is so
ridiculous that I've literally said to
people around me I go I I haven't been
drinking like I I know it looks like I
have like but I do that anyway these
slurs of my
own like I've like fallen down just like
walking and stuff like I fell out of a
cab once out of a cab I was getting out
of one of the minivan cabs and I slid
the door open and I went to step out and
I didn't realize that the step thing was
there and dude I literally fell forward
and landed on the pavement and hit my
head and I didn't cut it somehow I don't
know how wow I cracked two windshields
with my head what two windshields not
the same time in accident yeah oh well
yeah I guess so but what I mean what
happened um one I would think I told the
story but I was delivering pizza and I
looked down for a second as I was
driving to look at the address and when
I looked back up I had veered and I was
like 2T from a park car like I literally
was no way to get out of it I just went
ah held the wheel and I guess I wasn't
wearing my belt so when I came to the
car was in someone's yard if you
remember this big zii was I had long
Edie vet big ziti was strown about my
hair and literally pieces of glass the
windshield glass was in my hair and the
whole thing was spidered in every
direction and similar similar another
now here's a question I have about
windshield construction I wonder I
wonder is that a crazy question you know
you know you know those out of context
you know yeah yeah now here's a question
I have about window construction
windshield construction this is a
legitimate question I actually would
would like some responses from people on
this they're made to not right that you
mean well I was going to say is a
windshield is that crazy that your head
cracked it open or because it's a
windshield and thick or whatever or are
windshields made to give more easily
than we think because they're like guys
God forbid you go into this thing it you
you're better off going through it than
if it stops you cuz if it stops you're
going to break your neck question if I
had to guess I think they're probably
making the windshield as solid as
possible I don't think they're going to
manufacture the windshield for on the
off chances when people go through them
I think they're going to uh manufacture
them for you know quality control and
long lasting otherwise they're going to
get they're going to have a reputation
because then it's going to break you
know when a pine cone falls on it or
something well this is pimples up an I
didn't know that was a term anal a NE
glass typically breaks around 6,000
pounds per square inch so that's what my
head hit with
okay or PSI Federal specifications
dictate that tempered glass must have a
surface compression of at least 10,000
PSI it will usually break around
24,000 what's P oh pressure per square
inch pounds pounds of pressure basically
okay that's what PSI is yeah okay um all
right well there you go Jesus um well
all of this to say you look vibrant and
healthy and I'm sitting here with a gash
in my forehead um
oh we got merch we're supposed to plug
we got new merch yeah um we got the logo
finally yep we got this is a this is a
deep cut I think we need to give it more
like I think we need to get it out there
more CU I don't it happened in one
episode I'm not sure if we ever
reference it again I was just talking
about this earlier well it happened in
one episode I talked about getting
bullied when I was a kid by a kid named
Roger and I said Roger squeezed my head
and I lost it and then you said we
should make it into a shirt lo and
behold Roger squeezed my head shirts are
available we finally made it available
this is in my head how I always pictured
it V and I discussed V brought it to
fruition there it is Roger walks around
right now not knowing that his actions
caused you a core memory that was
unpleasant that now has been made into
merchandise with sale yeah is public at
large isn't that wild his name his
that's a specific Roger right there he
walks around I won't say his last name
but I he does not know it he doesn't
know I will tell you this though fans
did show up in Pittsburgh with Roger
squeez my head shirts that they had made
yeah themselves and that's when I was
like we got to get on that we got to
make ditch days right uh yeah yeah no I
mean yeah of I mean it's the same time
period yeah but staring into the ditch I
was younger again how did he squeeze
your head how does that happen he
grabbed like his hands he was so much
bigger than all of us he could Palm my
head like like it was the Giant and you
like Jimmy Hart and he reached around
like the top of my head and was like
squeezing into my temples basically so
he grab he Palm all the way down to the
temples he palmed your head and was
squeezing it yes so he genuinely had a
hand holding your head like it was a
melon yeah my mom lost her and he was
squeezing it yeah and you were uh you
were rendered uh
immobile yeah it hurt also he was
putting pressure on and were you
standing or sitting
I was I think I was standing I remember
being like bent over oh CU he was like
maybe also pushing down a bit Yeah he
was like literally like he meant to
damage my skull or whatever unprovoked
no I mean something happened when we
were playing he always bullied me okay
and he always picked on me but we were
NE we were kids in the same Suburban
neighborhood and all the kids played
together all the time and even the kids
that didn't always get along ended up
playing together
uh and then there were kids like Roger
who had a sack with balls of steel
inside of it that would beat you up in
your own home as your mother was just in
the other like inside the house that's
insane like so that's insane so like the
nuts on this kid like my mom came out
and like screamed at him and made him
leave but I'm like that is it didn't
dawn on me I was like cuz I kind of
thought like it's my backyard I'm I'm
like safe this is base I I would think
so you Wen you weren home home field
territory right no didn't wow that's
wild that Roger would disregard
HomeField advantages it's crazy and any
Authority that stands by I'll tell you
this would you would you allow me to do
something and I want you to think about
it before you answer is it squeezing my
head no okay would you allow me to get
Roger on this podcast and interview him
yeah I don't care really we became
friendly when we got older do he know he
squeezed yet I don't do he know that
that's a moment you remember does he did
he you became friends as you got older
and the bull went away and I oh yeah
when when we got this was when we were
eight or 10 or I don't remember but but
when we got into our
teens uh my okay so growing up my oldest
friend in the world is Scott
Hoffman and Scott and I are still very
close to this day Scott and I in fact
you met Scott once on my birthday yes
yeah so he's my oldest friend in the
world and we're very close Scott and
Roger went to high school together Scott
became friends with ro like he we knew
Roger cuz we again we're in the same
neighborhood but Scott became actually
quite friendly with Roger through high
school okay and I very much saw it as a
betrayal I would too he squeezed your
head and Scott would be like I'm telling
you dude he's like he's not that guy
anymore like he's a nicer guy like
whatever and then sure enough when I met
him REM met him or reconnected with him
because his family moved away when we
were like 16 or 17 I was like oh I like
this all right Roger he's nice like the
hook yeah it was the end of it so I
don't even know if I ever brought up to
him like do you remember you used to
bully me but a th% if you can get him on
this show so you know his last name so
we might to contact him via social media
or something like that I could call and
then I could have him come on and talk
about how he used to bully yeah you
Scott probably knows how to get in touch
with him really I would think look if
anybody does Scott does even if he just
calls in um but I would love to have him
right in front of me and take him to
task for it the uh the uh
where are all those bullies these text
my mom sends me are they're sick yeah
they're sick go she text me my your
orchid is coming back well they're
perennial and they take a while so I get
it she took an orch from my house that
was dying and she's nursing it back my
lost my orchids already I mean Jesus
Christ I'm not making a joke I have four
God bless as as you would say um today's
battle by the way they were four four
four orchids yeah wait why is that so
funny I guess it did I guess it sounded
like it was a joke and then it wasn't
just the fact that I have four orchids
it's funny to her amusing why is it when
I D they die they die but they come back
so you got to keep the pot and there's
four sticks that shoot out of it all
year long okay and I don't like points
so I had to bury in the corner and then
this year it was the first year they
would come back and only two or three
came back one didn't it's only you could
have I got as a gift and it was a lovely
gift it was a nice centerpiece on my
table for months it's a beautiful flower
when I bought my house as far as flowers
go it's Top Notch when I bought my house
the Realtors or the previous owners went
the extra mile and peppered plants
around the house so I felt
welcome this is after they already had
you no I yeah bought the house yeah they
already had you we're done and so you
afterwards you're like I I I wanted to
feel good about this transaction and so
they went and peppered plants I walked
into the bathroom there was there was a
potted orchid in in the bathroom it was
lovely they they wanted me to feel good
so they peppered plants around the house
there was and there was a sign on the
wall there was a sign on the wall when
you walked in that said welcome
home wow like a framed thing that they
put up really that's presumptuous they
went they went like the extra mile this
show is sponsored by betterhelp folks
it's the holiday season and it's time to
give some gifts it's also time to
receive some gifts does your family give
do the you guys exchange polyana
whatever look here's what I'm getting at
why don't you give yourself a gift the
gift of what the gift of therapy why is
therapy good well therapy is something
that helps you find the greatest gift of
all quiet in the
head being centered inside the heart and
and the the the this area here is that
when you use this because I know that
you do and I know that you like it is
that what you're trying to achieve quiet
in the head I'm trying to achieve quiet
in the head it's a lifelong battle for
is there any is there anything louder
than in here no you know what I mean
absolutely not so I I find that using
better help and and doing therapy
sessions with a therapist on better help
helps me especially at a time of year
like this where it gets hectic where it
gets noisy where it gets stressful take
some time to rest theing a tough moment
and also by the way you silence up here
and you start to focus on what's really
important about this time of year 100%
you know what I mean so if you are
thinking of starting therapy why not
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get match with a licensed therapist you
can switch therapist anytime and that's
no additional charge uh in the season of
giving give yourself what you need with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds today you're going to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com tastebuds I'm going to say
something you tell me what comes to mind
immediately America's number one meal
kit hellofresh that's exactly right
hello with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portion ingredients and seasonal
recipes is delivered right to your
doorstep you skip trips to the grocery
store and you count on hellofresh to
make home cooking easy fun and
affordable say hello to stress-free
holiday season with the help of
hellofresh skip the grocery store and
save time with easy Tasty Recipes
delivered to your door after a full day
of work there's only so much you could
do you want to come home especially
during the holidays and start that whole
that whole to-do of understanding what
you want to do and then coloring the
ingredients and by the way you want to
be standing in a checkout line you want
to be sipping cocoa
yeah you want to be sipping Coco that's
right right and and also sometimes it's
hard for people to come up with their
own wholesome dinner or a good meal but
with hellofresh you could turn busy week
nights into memorable meal times with
delicious practical options designed to
save you time like the 15minute meals
show yeah that's great man tons of
recipes they got over 45 recipes and
more than 100 seasonal add-on items to
choose from every single week uh it's
just really great uh they they have
something that everybody in the house
will enjoy hellofresh is look any
anybody helping you find more time for
yourself to breathe and less time to
worry about doing other stuff you don't
feel like you need to be doing they're
they're gems and by the way if you think
it's just dinner you're wrong it's also
breakfasts and and lunches and they have
10-minute lunch preps yeah yeah they
they're doing it right so go to
hellofresh.com taste buds and use
breakfast just started I just started
using the breakfast just want to let you
know and I have these uh like little
sausage and egg type of like things they
sent it was delicious I'm like literally
re-upped already all right yeah I love
it go to hellofresh.com tastebuds free
and use code tastebuds free for free
breakfast for Life One breakfast item
per box while subscription is active
that's free breakfast for life at
hellofresh.com taste buds free with code
taste buds free hellofresh americ number
one meal kit folks game time when it's
time to game folks game time keep it
yeah I love it when it's time to go to
the game or the theater or the comedy
show or the rock and roll show or the
hip-hop show you're going to want to use
game time or sports or the sports thing
well I already said when it's time to go
to the game oh oh the game yeah so
listen folks game time it's an app and
What it lets you do is it lets you buy
tickets whenever you feel like it okay
but really comes in handy if you want to
not have to buy these things way in
advance and it's going to let you know
that you are guaranteed getting the best
price for the best seats available uh
and it's also going to show you an
all-in price no hidden fees nothing like
that the number you see on that screen
that is what you are paying it drives me
crazy when I go buy a ticket and I go oh
wow like only 48 bucks that's pretty
good and then by the time you get to
check out it's like
270 what what is this when you buy by
touching a highlighted section like you
know 200 section and then you touch it
and it's like all right we'll give you
seats there I'm like wait where where
are the seats are they are they up here
are they up there I can't stand that one
thing they do is they you could see the
view from your seat and what you just
said all in prices and it's like it
literally is two Taps to buy the tickets
and they have a guarantee basically the
game time guarantee means you'll always
get the best price because if you find
tickets in the same section and row for
Less game time will credit you
110% of that difference and I also want
to point out something that we we don't
often say when we talk about game time
the exclusive Flash Deals are great
there are exclusive Flash Deals and
sponsored deals on tickets for football
and basketball and baseball and concerts
all this every live event you can think
of I I watched that thing last minute
and I'm just refreshing yeah it's cool
man uh anyway take the guesswork out of
buying tickets with Game Time download
the game time app create an account and
use code taste buds for $20 off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account and redeem code taste buds t
a s e b UDS for $20 off download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price guaranteed I don't know if it was
just the owners or if it was the realtor
you don't even know who that that that
that that never even met these people
wow but there was an orchid in my
bathroom that died within almost seconds
of me walking into the I don't know how
to keep you need sun there's sun in the
bathroom what is it what do you think
was it potted yeah oh okay yeah no it
was potted like cutting in a vas it
looked like very
it looked like very like Mr Miyagi style
yeah like it was very like there was
like little pebbles in the pot a
bathroom what are you talking about
there's Sun you're not supposed to put
an orchid in direct sunlight you're
not why do you know that cuz I looked up
how to keep it alive still screwed it up
but what I'm saying is not everybody has
a window in their bathroom many bathroom
mine does all right yeah but you were
like this
sun I feel like not having a new a
window in your bathroom is a New York
thing that we've all accepted that's not
normal for any other part of the country
I got a room I got a bedroom in my house
with no
windows it's insane I had one too and it
was the only bedroom in the apartment
it's just crazy I me the city you're
like it's normal to just have a sink in
the kitchen and nowhere else you know
it's it's so nuts um so the the merch
just to go back to it Ro that's Rog just
squeeze my head yes we might get him in
here and we might get him under the
under the spotlight what else we got
Davey that would be huge on the merch
uh we have the as you said the logo you
go to no
press.com noes network.com
merch we got the logo we got the we got
a reup on the no matter what happens I
love you but now you can get it on like
seven different colors one of them is a
canary yellow that is just Grand if you
ask me I love it you can get any of
these on multiple colors so we had an
image we had some artwork drawn up that
we made limited edition um uh signed uh
numbered 8 by10 for for the uh live
stream which sold out in 10 minutes I
think it was 250 of them yes they sold
out in 10 minutes we have that now on a
shirt yes which is really cool and then
we have a picture of me a real picture
of me you and Chris uh CH Oh that's oh
this you know what's great about that
picture oh God this is this is uh
moments before and they put a clip out
of it this is moment before I left there
went directly to j& R's live taping and
crashed the
taping who took that photo I think V did
oh right really look at that photo cred
goes to V I got to say none of us look
great in that picture it's hard to see
from here it's a good picture I look I
look like a full-fledged drunk in this
picture uh Chris this it the second time
you are on a
shirt right cuz you you got you made
those sleepy Joe hoodies I have oh wait
I forgot about the Sleepy Joe hoodies
you don't remember that uh no oh yeah
you fell sleepy I forgot Halloween in a
Batman you took a picture and then we
put you put it on a hoodie yeah I forgot
about that um Everybody forgot about you
look
S I don't know how to say it like a
woman man I feel like a woman let me uh
can you zoom in there's a womanish
quality to you in this in this photoin
on it can we Zoom I don't mean that it's
bad to be a woman but that's not the
look you're going for you got a little
bit of a kagy and Lacy Vibe going in
this I look like a female detective from
1979 I'm saying you look like Ty daily a
little bit in this picture Ty daily
Broadways Ty daily huh Broadway's Ty
daily she's on Broadway currently in a
Revival of Doubt with Lev shriber no way
she is is it Lev I thought it was leev
uh leev Lev I don't know all right Pat
Walsh texted me he texted me it said uh
it was just the poster said doubt a
parable starting love driver and time
daily and I wrote back this is why we're
friends only you and I understand why
this is funny for some reason and he
just wrote back I assumed she died years
ago wow I mean that no one even knows
what you're talking about against room
but even in in our our our podcast
listeners they don't know who kagne and
Lacy is uh I am going to go see that cuz
love the movie doubt and I want to see
the play and I'm a fan of both of those
actors and I'm going to go see it well
there you have it and you think I look
like I'm there you got a I'm saying
there's a VI can you pull up a picture
of Ty daily there's a
Vibe then and now no just just to
that t y n e yeah it's a weird
name so you think I look like her hold
on there's a little bit let's click back
she looks wonderful by the way there's a
little bit
do you really wa wait wait show her on
KAG and Lacy you can't show her now with
the gray
hair oh my god wow that lined up that
led up even more than I thought it would
I think it's because we're in 70s attire
and we have the same color hair other
than that haut too you got the you got
the same color oh that's that's I
can't believe that you pulled th daily
out it was uh and then Chris let's go
back to
Chris Chris looks like like like a
there's something like what's going on
Chris has got a thing going on this
picture he's got a he he looks like the
devil or something look at
his a devilish G it's a devilish gri for
sure yeah and and what are you doing who
are you pointing to what are you doing
there oh we're pointing to the ice penis
oh I didn't even notice the ice penis I
I didn't even notice it I I I would have
bought that shirt and not you know what
people are going to buy that shirt and
not notice there's a huge ice penis on I
would have noticed it it just Blends
into the background you don't see it did
you know it was an ice you took it
that's
fine did you realize there was an ice
penis on it Pim no you didn't I think
it's fine it doesn't matter right
no no it doesn't matter at all I'm just
saying that's hysterical oh the ice
penis is because there was a he had
you're both pointing at it and I didn't
notice it with that neither did I I I
thought I was just doing like this like
like like making like a hip hoppy pose
and then I Rose oh no I'm pointing at
that ice P it was what is that called a
Lou a shot
Lou Chris had a shot Louge at his
birthday party that Jasmine had bought
him this was a surprise thing and uh it
was a it was a penis that you had to put
your mouth on the tip of I said what did
it say house yeah I I uh no surprise
here I decided not to engage I I hit
that thing like six times
man the uh um oh so okay well we got to
get to the the battle um um we're
probably pretty well where are we at no
press network.com merch check it out so
the battle today is a Christmas themed
battle it's gift giving which do you
prefer receiving or giving mhm uh we are
aware
that
receiving is going to seem selfish that
that's going to seem selfish you know
but we really try to push for answer
honestly don't just say giving because
you think it's the way to sound nice
right 100% like I genuinely feel the way
I feel and not anyone who knows me knows
that I actually don't even like
necessarily receiving I actually don't
even necessarily like it per se okay and
there's a you know because you more so
than not like for example my mom texted
me that day she like what do you want
for Christmas I'm like M I have no idea
I don't know what to tell you I don't
want you to waste your money on me uh
you know and then what happens is she'll
go and get something and give it to me
and I feel even more guilty because I
don't like it and then I got to return
it or keep it and for me I'd rather not
go through all that Hubb at all my mom
and dad will they do the same thing
thing my mom asks me every year starting
on December 1st she starts pressuring me
literally like every day like send me
your list I do the same thing every year
I send her an Amazon list that I can
share with her I make sure every single
thing on it is prime ready I go this
these are the things that would would be
okay uh she she chooses from
that she usually it's not usually a ton
of stuff okay she will ruin it every
year by by as I'm opening the first
present going I got you just everything
on the list and takes all the surprise
out of it I wish you would just pick
like a couple things and I'd be like oh
wow cool but like I'm just trying to I'm
not saying to her buy me these things
I'm saying like I'm just trying to make
it easy for you um of but her and my dad
will go off the res a little bit and and
buy me a couple things they they think I
like yeah they'll take yeah and usually
some of what's their success with those
the one thing I the the one non success
one that I had to tell my mom you got to
stop with these she was buying me a
calendar every
year and and and one yeah a hanging
calendar hanging
calendar and but the the the themes of
these calendars were were terrific they
were bat can I guess yeah how many have
you gotten she's done it for a few years
I 10 10 that I can remember oh so you
got it every year oh yeah it was a gift
every my mom would say to me you know I
had to get you a calendar know oh that's
so cute it is sweet so all right so do
you remember a lot lot of them so if I
take start taking guesses I remember two
of them in particular okay I don't know
if she got cutesy with it and got you
like dogs and that's the joke or if not
there's no joke to any of them there's
no it wasn't a joke to her but could it
be something like dogs if it's not a
joke to her could be okay so then that
that opens up a wide cuz I was going to
be like architecture or whatever no all
right that' been nice okay all right
dogs there was one that was either dogs
or cats and I said to her as she handed
me I go
what is
this that's that that's a good thing to
hear when you're giving a gift go that's
the risk I take giving I go I go I don't
understand Mom why did you get me this
that was the last year that was the last
year it was like two years ago or three
years ago so let me ask you question go
but but but wait I go I go why why did
why did you why did you get me the the
animal themed one and she goes I just
thought it would brighten your day to
see to look at a dog every I go Mom
listen I understand that's a nice
thought it won't and I don't need a
calendar anymore just please I use my
phone I I'll never use it please stop
wasting your money on these yeah you
know I I probably in that moment she
would have given me the power to
associate to that moment and that
gesture and I would have probably kept
it and every time I looked at it as
ridiculous as it was for me to have that
it would brighten my day because she got
it to brighten my day that's the
difference between you and
me you are well within the power do that
I I I never even thought of it that way
as you're saying it I'm like I should
have kept all the calendars that would
have been fun to be able to be like and
then there's this one let me think of
another one you want to guess again yeah
okay I'm gonna say like
um
beaches no no the other one that I can
remember it's to me it's so funny it's
so funny hint I love games it's just
like when I looked at it I was like she
thinks I'm 11 years old like this is
insane Star Wars no no I would have
liked that I would have liked that or
like you know like if it was like comic
book themed or something
no let me just tell you it'll be funnier
cars it was different cars you're not
known to like cars right no it was like
it was like Ferraris or something I was
like I'm not a child this is crazy food
I should have got that
I think there was a time the calendar
might have been a little more
spoton okay some of them have definitely
just been like
calendars like there's nothing I mean
like like just a straight up like
there's no even theme to it religious
any religious no religious ones but like
you know I I I'm shocked she never got
me one of like women in bikinis like it
was like it it was like so crazy to I
they go with they have ones with women
bikinis with the cars as well she could
have doubled down yeah this one had no
chicks it was just the cars um but I
will say this they will nail it on
certain things okay so they give me a
nail oh dude one one I'll give you two
of the two two of the best ones um I had
no coffee mugs they came to my apartment
for Thanksgiving one year and I didn't
have enough coffee mugs MH and my dad
got
me uh this set of Star Wars coffee mugs
and it was like it it was like nine it
was like oh wow yeah it was like Luke
Yoda Vader Emperor Darth like it was
like you know or it was it was awesome I
was like oh that's a good that's a good
gift and then another year they gave me
two coffee table
books one and they're beautiful books
about cars and dogs about cars and dogs
one was the complete Visual History of
DC Comics and the other was the complete
Visual History of Marvel Comics like
that's an awesome
paid attention yeah like I have those
like displayed like that's a fun book
for guests to pick up and flip through
and whatever in my house right now it's
a case of uh the drama comes from a case
of too many mugs for quite some time now
the what did you say too many mugs in my
house right now you got too many mugs
there bickering about the mugs now
really cuz you know you you know mugs
are like umbrellas too like you
sometimes you'll buy one you're like oh
what a cool mug but a lot of times you
just get them they're in like as a gift
or like they just I don't know how mugs
get to be
but I I have like probably over 20 mugs
I have a rule with mugs and with uh um
why's it called the
mug with mugs and with cocktail glasswar
not not you're drinking every day but
like stuff that I have like in this
house like I'm setting up these this far
area
um beer mugs in the late 18th century
okay according to web Garrison and why
you say it beer mugs of the late 18th
century were often shaped like human
heads and a not especially attractive
person often bore a resemblance to a
face on a
mug oh that's where it became oh my God
that's why they call your face your mug
oh wait wait I'm sorry oh wait no that's
why a face is called a
mug this isn't why is a mug called a
right why is a mug called a
mug
a cup becomes a mug when Li I hate when
they tell you like that when liquid
is poured in thank you guys with liquid
there really uh mug meaning a cup used
for drinking dates back to the mid-6th
century it's origin uncertain linguists
have suggested it came from low
German m m
Muk mug or the German word though the
origin is unknown I don't know that's
weird it's just a Swedish or German word
that's boring dude so I have so anyway I
have a feeling you are going to be re
like appalled by this what I'm about to
say but trust me it's it's a good way to
do it I will only buy mugs M coffee mugs
and cocktail like stuff for Booze from
thrift
stores because you go in you will always
find a unique yeah that's cool you got I
watch the out of it
but like that Thrift is where you're
going to find like you're like look at
these two rocks glasses that have like
this weirding whatever so that's I
always go like for so that's there's
your mug answer yeah I got a my one of
the ashtrays I use we got a we got old
ashtrays oh they're the best for ashtray
so we got too many mugs so now like some
we've purchased some I've accumulated
from things like if I'm gift like this
you know or going on something or
whatever it is people send them and now
there's too many and now it's a it's a
fight about who's going to throw out
their mugs not a fight but like and and
it's a stalemate it's been a stalemate F
who's going to throw out there you you
each get to keep the same amount why is
that a
fight I don't know I don't know who has
more I really don't I just know there's
too many and I'm always being asked to
get rid of mine and recently I think she
got rid of two more we're at the point
where the mugs are we stacking mugs on
mugs but they handles and I'm I'm really
afraid of them breaking uh my buddy Jim
pinkstone who I've mentioned on the
podcast what are you laughing at the
name you just it it's some I like the
way you speak okay thank you his entire
he and his wife uh their house PST Mrs
pinkstone uh they have their house their
entire cabinet like all of their glass
all of it every single glass mug juice
anything is something like like unique
that they got from some every every
single thing it's like it's like the
Burger King Return of the Jedi glass the
Hamburglar glass the what like it's they
have the greatest drinking wear s I've
ever seen yeah I have the most saved the
wrapped in like newspaper and in a box
like the Star Wars ones the the
McDonald's ones yeah yeah their glasses
are so cool I swear when I stay with
them I get anxiety when I go to get a
drink cuz I open I'm like I don't want
to I don't want to take any of these CU
afraid to break them I'm going to break
always like put them out use them right
enjoy them right which she has a point
but I'm like they're from the
70s you know like I if I if I break one
of them I'm going to be so upset well I
just found out you're not supposed to
actually drink I forget who was just
telling me this I think it was my friend
Caitlyn you're not supposed to drink out
of those glasses cuz there's like a
there's like a a lead or something in
the
paint yeah that that that you should
just have them on display and that's it
okay well that's a huge thing I'm not
sure which ones exactly
is something here cuz I want to get back
into this battle the battle okay so all
right let's do the chant time two b a t
oh boy somebody's been away haven't type
two b a t t l e buds Todd Barry was here
I've never seen someone less interested
in a chant in my entire life than Todd
Barry the uh um okay so the battle is
giving versus receiving I am team giving
Salis team I'm sorry I am team receiving
Salis team giving um the reason that we
have the reminder there with Ru garbage
is and it's one of the one of my I love
giving but one of my problems with
giving is is what we talked about when
Ru garbage is here which is there is a
pressure that I feel when it comes to
the economics of giving a gift and this
also applies to receiving I have friends
that buy way too expensive gifts and
their opinion is buddy I have it I can
afford it let me share it with you but
when you're receiving it it makes me so
I do a thing every year with my four
buddies uh from back home Scott who I
mentioned is one of them Jim who I
mentioned is one of them and then my
buddies Jamie and Dan we do a thing
called Eve Eve every December 23rd we do
a bar crawl then we go back to one of
our houses shitfaced and give each other
pres Trad we've doing it for 22 years or
something it's awesome Scott without
fail we we're like you know $100 range
so you're getting you know you get a DVD
a Blu-ray box set from somebody or you
know oh I got you these really cool
comic books that I thought you you know
whatever then you open Scotts and it's
like you know how you love Frank Zappa
here's an autographed guitar pick that I
got from his estate and it's framed and
you're like come on dude I do this to my
family so so it's awesome but you're
like it's you're like dude I can't
with this like you're going you know
know so are you garbage when they were
here we were talking about when you if
you're garbage which I am when you go to
a person's
home you bring a gift sometimes you
contribute something and garbage people
like myself tend to overspend on that
gift or buy too much of it because you
are afraid that you don't belong there
or or or so give me an example something
you buy too much of I'll give you a
great example the first time I ever came
to your house um when we had that big
sleepover right before Co started it was
like you me Jay Ari right yeah everyone
crash and and and I had it was I was
kind of being brought into the group we
were friendly and friends but I was not
part of the crew and I was being brought
in and I spent like I spent like
$150 on like timens and cookies remember
it was so insane that much money yeah
cuz I bought dude I bought so and we
didn't eat any of it but like I'll do
that because I start to get in my head
and I'm like if I show up and I'm not
contributing enough I you know you was
walking you're like is the timen's line
yeah yeah yeah so um so like that's an
example okay so there's there's a
there's a pressure with giving okay so
the thing about the giving I I don't
really focus on the the co the cost good
or bad you know I I focus on like um
there's people that I know giving gifts
to Christmas time or when have whatever
I also like if something I
see I think someone would like it I will
just buy it right like it doesn't have
to be like anything for anything right
like I think I was I was you know that
um photographer Danny clinch nope famous
like rolling like uh Rock like music
photographer I went to uh I he was I was
in SoHo and he was having like this
signing of all his works and I passed by
and I saw him and I actually had one
that o ODB that someone got from oh oh
yeah that I know that picture yeah and
um I saw he he used to be fish's
photographer okay and so I bought a fish
print and he signed it and I got it for
fooya because he a big fish guy you know
I was like so excited I get more
excitement in knowing that I have a
really good gift that the person will
enjoy than getting a gift well there's
here's I I I love it I just love to make
people happy and I love to like show
that there's thought put into something
so for me I give you running list in my
note in my notes on my phone throughout
the year if I see something I think
someone likes so when Christmas time
comes I'm not racking my brain and I
have stuff that's a deep cut that I know
I try to do that too I try to do that
too this year Christmas got botched by
Co the last two years for me so I am
really behind the eightball this year I
I was I'm so terrified it's going to get
ruined again that I have not you act
quick babe cuz you're you're going to
get screwed with those shippings I know
I know well I got one person's gift in
or in line my parents the old whatever
I'm going to digress the okay so I
actually enjoy giving quite a bit the
older I am but I will say this about and
I don't mean this I'm giving you're
receiving no I know I know but this is
what I was going to say about you're
giving I and I I swear to you I don't
mean this in a
whatever you you have you I think the
let's put it this way I'll put it in my
own terms the older I get and the more
financially stable I become the less
reive
becomes the more fun part of it sure I
still like it though a lot right but I
you know now you've been you've been you
know uh uh uh the show's been the show's
been big for a while right so I feel
like that probably had an influence when
you get to a point where you're like I
have what I need and I can you know what
I mean right right as far as getting
stuff yeah it's it's more exciting than
to take some of what you have and go let
me let me do a really cool thing for a
friend or whatever we are we also are
attaching like
uh value monetary value to gifts when
that doesn't have to be the case at all
so it's not something that oh what do
you get for a person who could buy
whatever they want no it's like it's
also no I'd be blown away if I got
something that didn't cost anything that
was just very very thoughtful I agree I
agree the thought also becomes the mon I
hate the monetary part of it yeah with
I'll speak on it from receiving I hate
the ever in my life were not gifts that
you could or even if they were cheap
they were like you know of the craziest
gifts I ever got it was one of the most
thoughtful gifts I ever got Pete Holmes
and I love Glen Gary Glenn Ross like
we've been quoting Glenn Gary Glenn Ross
to each other since we've become friends
for 20 years whatever we we have quoted
it ad nauseum every L shout out to Pete
Holmes new special on Netflix it was
really funny yes check it out we uh we
like to to the point like we we have a
game we play where I'll text him and
I'll be like I'll be like uh
uh
you know I think maybe you're having a
effects from the hitting your head it's
probably
right you searching for Words more I'll
be like Glen Gary Glenn Christmas you
and you have to take a Glen Gary Glenn
Ross line and make it a Christmas
reference and it's so challenging but it
we we scream laughing at it we scream
laughing at it whatever so anyway
there's this scene in when Alec
Baldwin's giving the Spiel to the guys
where he goes you know what it takes to
C takes to take brass balls and he pulls
the brass balls out of suitcas Pete got
me those brass balls not the ones from
the movie but he found those right and
gave them to me and I'm like this is
such an insane GI like it's so
thoughtful and it also makes you think
of that you know that's the perfect gift
yeah so so yeah so I should strud I
should sell them they're probably is
brass worth money is that are you are
you asking me or is that a quote from
the movie no I'm saying I could Pawn the
if I'm at a pinch but I don't think
brass is worth anything the um were at
48 okay um so look there's let me let me
talk about pros of receiving the pros of
receiving I
mean look it doesn't matter how old you
get when someone lands it it's great
when someone lands it a general sense I
don't want you to waste your money on me
I actually feel guilt receiving I really
do I I I attach guilt to it sometimes I
feel bad especially if it's coming from
like my parents or you know ever or like
not it's not I feel good but like I I'm
more I'm like please don't don't spend
your money it's okay like I don't want
you to but then I want to give them 10
gifts you know me I get that and I
actually I've been called out on that
like it's like you should be able to
accept it if you're going to go ahead
and go overboard and give everybody else
gifts I will say this I will say this
the there there there is
no there's just nothing though like
receiving a
package a you know the the being hand
handed a thing that you element surprise
I I lose completely in my argument but I
get to see you enjoy the element of
surprise so I'm enjoying it I'm we're
enjoying the same thing if I give you a
gift that you love and I love giving it
to you the heights are there there's
there's the anticipation of opening
something they they do it on Seinfeld
when he gets the package and c and he
doesn't he he refuses it yeah could be a
bomb and cr's like come on man everybody
loves receiving a package like
that's true I get excited when packages
for things I ordered show up yeah I
usually not just because I'm happy the
thing is here I get excited about
opening the box and looking at it for
the first and all stuff there's I don't
know if there's any anticipation or
excitement on planet Earth that matches
what a present does to you it's so fun
it's so fun here's my touche is that
what I just said it's like one of the
happiest moments that I that I feel like
can achieve too is when I have a
thoughtful gift that I know someone's
going to love I'm so happy I thought of
it I'm so excited to give to them and
see see you experience what you just
said coming from me directly that is I'm
I'm right there here's what I'll tell
you you don't get with the giving side M
you don't get to understand how much
another person I got to rap it that
sucks I hate rapping that's that's that
blows I ha it I use it blows a lot of
times I use aluminum foil
no scissors no scissors no
what if it's small enough I use aluminum
foil aluminum foil yeah no scissors no
tape it's shiny why am I you get a
Christmas aluminum you talking about
like Reynolds right about Reynolds get
out of here Duty you trash heavy
duty that's terrible why that's terrible
I rap too I do a very terrible job but I
I i' I've did that for I mean countless
gifts I put in in aluminum foil saying
it out loud now it really upsets listen
to me bro insane listen to me all you
need is the foil first of all you you
spend extra on the good wrapping paper
and that usually includes some type of
foil Leaf the good wrapping paper is the
good wrapping paper don't tell me you
don't know this tear of wrapping paper
no I go to Target and I buy like fun but
even at Target there's
tears and if you go the extra mile it's
probably less less in a roll but it
usually has gold like a foil shiny foil
so it it has it in there that's you you
got to help me remember Adam for cuz
it's a gift story wait a minute wait a
minute on either side this kind of
wrapping paper sucks anything with the
shine to it where it's like it's almost
like you wrapped it in like Saran WRA
you know that shiny that wrapping paper
sucks if it is not the tear away paper
paper yeah bab I would I would take
plain brown paper you know what I love
wrapping paper I don't like wrapping
gifts but I love wrapping paper I like
look under the tree and see seen all the
different kinds scanning it and looking
at it and all that stuff and I love
ripping open a gifts okay the part of
receiving that I do like about it is I
love when the gifts are ripped open at
Christmas I'm a proponent I I'm a a
supporter of rip open the gift throw the
wrapping paper right all night long
right I want to be walking in a sea of
wrapping paper at my feet okay like a
wrapping paper swamp Okay I love that I
have people in my family that don't and
that they literally hand you the gift
and they hold they're holding a glad bag
a garbage bag and then you wrap it they
go give me that and they put it right
into the bag and I'm like I I'd like to
take the paper back no no like they
throw it away they don't leave it all
over the floor immediately yeah I like
to leave it sometimes on Christmas
morning if I'm at my parents house on
Christmas morning sometimes we leave the
paper out and the dogs like playing it
yeah that that's another thing I would
like to ask as far as wrapping people go
what do you do you like to keep it all
over the house and or do you clean it
after I got OCD I start like I start
like picking it up as soon as it hits
the ground and and I have to remind
myself like no let the dog play with it
or whatever for a minute also let me
tell you another thing with receiving
the pendulum swings both ways you could
also bomb big time and then you put that
person in position to look you in the
face and tell you they like it and then
you don't even know if they've taken it
and ever used it and resold it and
regifted it we've there's nothing worse
than a bad gift and there's nothing
worse than the feeling but what's worse
receiving a bad gift or the feeling have
when you realize you did a botch job on
a gift give feeling usually you don't
know that unless you're very close with
someone and they say usually you receive
the gift and you don't tell that person
and then you you off off some of the
only people that I give gifts to yeah
are these four guys I'm talking about
and then my parents and then like I
think we're at a you've been you've
bought me gifts I can't remember if I've
ever bought you Christmas present but I
certainly would if I saw something that
I thought you would enjoy but my my
point is is is I I know immediately with
those guys cuz it rotates you have each
one guy has the other guy whatever one
guy I know immediately if I hit it or if
I didn't you we've all gotten gifts that
we regifted right and and we and I'm
sure we've all given gifts that were
regifted um is when you regift
something and you think it sucks how do
you get the courage to give it as a gift
to somebody
else what do you mean so I get this gift
like this is a terrible gift right it's
a terrible gift right thank you so much
but then I want to give it to somebody
else but it's terrible so I I'm aware
that I'm giving you a terrible gift I'm
regifting my terrible gift to you I
don't think I don't think that that's
what it is which is another yeah that's
another that's another sefel too the
label maker where keeps getting regifted
the but I don't think that that's baby
Jun I don't think that that's a thing or
is I think there's a version of that
that works which is you give me a thing
it's not for me I'm not into it but I'm
like you know that maybe V I think Vena
might actually like this I wouldn't do
that because then you you'd see me do it
right but let's say I had another
podcast producer on another show that I
thought might like it I would I would
you catch someone re giting something
you gave one I one stands out to me yeah
yeah no yeah I gave someone a gift and
but it was like a couple of years a year
to two years later and I saw it uh on
eBay wow how wait and you knew they were
at just you knew they were selling it
yeah how on eBay but I'm saying like
nobody on eBay is like my name is you
know hey it's Mark Norman here's my eBay
post I know the person like you knew
their eBay handle is what I'm saying I
can't get into how I found out okay it's
nothing nothing on my end it's just like
I don't want to give away who it is I
got you I got you wait um but it didn't
bother me I I was like ah that sucks I
thought they would like that it didn't
because I I I gave other gifts too here
is why here is why I I this is my
crowning argument for receiving over
giving and let's do it yeah yeah let's
do what go to the phon you go to the
phones yeah okay you don't know through
giving how much another person loves you
but there is a moment sometimes when
somebody gives you a gift where you
realize how much they think about you
well that's that is an incredibly
incredibly beautiful moment I will just
tell you a quick story and it wasn't a
birthday or nice Dismount yeah wasn't a
birthday or
anything uh I was I was out Adam Ferrara
great comic he and I become very good
friends um he and I like in the period
where we were really becoming friends we
started like talking on the phone having
these deep like discussions stuff we
went and got dude I remember it was
right before covid it was right before
Co we went to a diner it was Vela love
it yeah and and they were they ended up
being closed that day or whatever but
there was a guy outside and he was
washing down he was like he had his toes
and he was washing all this equipment
off with it and uh Adam Adam goes he
goes let me show you something he walked
me around the corner I saw the guy
shooting he goes somebody coughed in
here 5 minutes ago and were laughing
like wouldn't it be funny if Co got that
ridiculous little do we know and then
like two weeks later that's where it was
at you know it was crazy so uh anyway we
went to a different place and he kept
talking all day about he's like I got to
go to Barnes &
Noble I was like all right I missed the
process of going to a bookstore and
picking out a book it's the best so then
we got to we finished EA and he's like
he's like is there a Barnes in and yeah
yeah there's that one right in Union
Square and he's like all right I got to
go up there you want to walk with me and
I'm like yeah so we're walking it's a
beautiful day we're just talking about
life whatever he's telling me about this
book he wants to get blah blah blah we
find it he buys it we walk outside and
he goes dude today was great he reaches
in the bag and he hands me the book and
he goes that's for you and like he spent
all this time telling me about this book
and how much it meant and why he wanted
it and the philosophy and all this stuff
and then we go to the store and he's
he's really smokes screening me and he
gives it to me cuzz was like this is all
the stuff I hear you worrying about all
the time I want you to read this it was
so like in that moment dude you could
cry yeah so so so that aspect of
receiving sorry for the F that a that
aspect of receiving a
gift there's a beauty and giving but I
don't know that you can find intimately
understand in one instant how much a
person truly thinks about you okay I'll
Dismount real quick actually I just got
a gift a couple of weeks ago that made
me cry my buddy Mike got uh the Vic made
uh he got a model made of the Vic and
and I was like this is an
insane insane idea like it's so it was
so like you know put my so anyway but I
that was beautiful and
Nate's yeah can I say Nate's text or
yeah yeah I had to move I had to move
tickets last minut South Tex is a
picture of the model and Nate just
responded he goes other shows not sold
out inside the model
either
on the group text that was really funny
um it was really really funny um what
was I gonna say oh I would just argue
real quick that like if I'm giving a
gift of that magnitude to someone yeah I
do know them that well and I do know
like you're saying it I don't know how
much you love me if I'm giving you the
gift when you receive it you could tell
how much that person loves you yeah but
I'm saying if I'm giv a gift like that
anyway it's because I already understand
how much sure sure there's a huge and
that's the thing if I were to get you
something there's no there's no losers
here there's no losers there's no losers
it wouldn't it be funny if it was 50/50
well listen I know I I know one or two
losers in my life that hate the idea of
exchanging present so much that that by
the worst presence I've
ever all right name names so we got to
go to the phone let's go to the phon all
right garlic skin says I bet the Rosa
gives out action figures as adults to as
Christmas gifts you're right I'd rather
give because I don't like receiving
shitty gifts and pretending to be
excited there you go the feeling of Joy
I've gotten from really getting someone
a great gift has always stuck with me
more than most gifts I received so I've
got a very well thought
out giving getting gifts is nice but I
prefer to give I'm going to get cramed I
love to craft and make personal
gifts gift giving is my love language as
I as I have been told it is mine you
know that's one of them that's a real
thing yeah what gift giving is a love
language I'll tell you I my birthday is
November 6th since I can remember
remember all the money I got on my
birthday November 6 I would use to buy
my family Christmas gifts every single
year I've been buying them gifts since
I'm like five really yeah wow you were
one of those kids I I I I don't know
what's wired up here to you know to for
me to feel good like by doing that but
dude every single person is saying I
prefer to give all right okay look these
are the show boers we'll see in the vote
cuz I have a feeling people might this
be 100% to zero will this be will this
be the biggest do we know what the
biggest was in history I think it was
like not that long ago but here's the
thing here's the thing what are you
going to say out loud these are the
people speaking out loud we got a lot of
anonymous votes in that thing where we
might see receive pops up true I'd said
be honest search yourself on this on
this poll because cuz it's okay to say
it doesn't mean you're selfish you could
still like which do you prefer I know
prefer but this is like the Oscars in my
opinion everybody goes oh it doesn't
matter if I win I just want to be oh
you want to win so that's the
thing you like to get a present
we all like to give but it's fun to get
presents what right now what do you
think this percentage is it's got to be
right it's got to be 90s it's it's it's
100 Zer right now I didn't see one thing
that said I liked receiving presents
once we hit 80s it's like it's like it's
like whoa I think I know all right pimpy
here we go drum
roll wow much closer than thought much
closer than we thought okay gift giving
68.2% takes it to receiving a gift at
31.8 that was
actually a normal kind of that wasn't
bad battle I thought you were gonna get
walloped no I thought so too all right
uh I still love you babe love you
too they hate talking about the food
they like two fools going to fight but
only one food can be right tast buds man
yeah they coming to the